in 2010 then governor of california
arnold schwarzenegger visited japan
korea and china marveling at their
high-speed trains
china's those still in their infancy
were already faster than any in america
by about 120 miles or 190 kilometers an
hour
california's ambitions were modest by
comparison to build one line from san
francisco to l.a about 70 percent the
length of china's longest by 2020 ten
years later
a second phase would connect la to san
diego down south and merced to
sacramento up north
ten years later california was somehow
still 10 years away
meanwhile the cost had grown from 33
billion in the 2008 proposal to 53
billion in 2012 to 77 in 2018. two and a
third times the original estimate
still it gets worse
in an embarrassing illustration of
american bureaucracy its trains if and
when they ever exist will have two sets
of doors at different heights for
different stations after failing to
compromise with caltrain
then there's china
while california was busy bickering over
the height of its doors and fending off
lawsuits
china put its head down and just built
even after becoming number one in
high-speed rail it never looked back
charging forward until it had surpassed
every other nation put together
then two-thirds of the entire world
total
more impressive is that it did all this
as a middle-income country
at the time it began construction its
per capita gdp was just 3 400 current
u.s dollars
if you adjust the length of each
nation's high-speed rail by gdp per
capita few others are even visible
but trains are only one high-profile
symbol of a much larger pattern
that while china's methods may be crude
and controversial they are ultimately
more efficient
the country has dramatically more
electric buses for instance than
anywhere else on the planet by a crazy
margin
one city even built an elevated bus lane
allowing them to zoom past traffic jams
so too does its number of electric
charging stations dwarf all other
regions by comparison
while congress hems and haws about big
tech monopolies chinese authorities just
snap their fingers and break them up
american politicians it's often said
think only one election cycle ahead
whereas chinese leaders are free to plan
50 or 100-year grand strategies
or so it may seem
sponsored by skillshare get a one-month
free trial and start learning everything
from photography to graphic design
there are three ingredients to
successful high-speed rail
first and most obvious you need lots of
people
not just a large number but ideally a
string of high-density clusters
check
the vast majority of the 100 chinese
cities with a population over 1 million
are quite conveniently clumped together
on its eastern coastal side
second it can't be too expensive
again no problem
in addition to the much lower cost of
labor the sheer scale of china's plans
allowed construction companies to
optimize every step of the process and
amortize large investments over
significantly longer time and project
horizon
a report by the world bank found that
its average cost was at least 40 percent
cheaper than the european equivalent
it didn't hurt that everything up to and
including the trains themselves were
built in china
third and finally a good candidate for
high-speed rail is rich
this it most certainly was not
but with annual gdp growth over 10
percent at the time it wasn't crazy to
think it would soon get there
its first few routes connected wealthy
first second and third tier cities like
nanjing the fifth richest to guangzhou
the thirteenth
they were also the right length
for trips shorter than roughly 100 miles
it generally makes more sense to drive
or take a bus especially given that many
stations are far outside city centers
conversely for trips longer than about
750 miles it's usually preferable to fly
these journeys take upwards of five
hours on even the fastest trains
the space between 100 and 750 miles but
especially below 500 is the goldilocks
zone for high-speed rail
too far to drive yet not far enough to
fly
eight out of its first 10 routes had
total lengths within these bounds
it all seemed pretty sensible
and had it stopped there in 2010 it
would still today have the longest
high-speed rail network of any country
even building nothing new for the next
12 years it would still go down in
history as a tremendous accomplishment
in speed scale and cost
instead china kept building and building
and building and building
now this wasn't its original intention
far from a grand strategic plan it's
along with much of what we know as
modern china today were reactions
reactions to the 2008 financial crisis
45 percent of its nearly 600 billion
dollar stimulus package went toward
transport and power infrastructure
it seemed like the perfect time to seize
the opportunity and get ahead rather
than sit back and wait until its
infrastructure was already crumbling
like the us
but it was still at its core a gamble
one giant assumption that demand would
materialize and that increased
interconnectivity would drive greater
economic growth
this was not a sound a bet as it may
seem
for anyone living in the u.s or other
rich countries high-speed rail probably
looks like a cheaper more
environmentally sound alternative to air
travel
but the data clearly shows that in china
the biggest competitor to high-speed
trains are older cheaper low-speed
trains
in a 2015 survey about half of all
passengers said they otherwise would
have taken conventional trains
only a small minority say they would
have flown
the problem is cost
one study found the average cost to
build a 350 kilometer an hour line was
90 percent higher than even a 250
kilometer one which is still by the way
considered high speed
this is in large part because the faster
lines use elevated tracks which given
china's softer soils would compress and
sink over time causing a safety risk
to prevent this the fastest trains
require extensive use of bridges and
viaducts which are significantly more
expensive than road bed made of sand
rock and gravel
and that's just the construction
these are not legos build once and play
forever they also have operating costs
energy use is not linear with respect to
speed electricity consumption increases
much faster with every additional
kilometer per hour
all of this is to say that extra bit of
speed is really expensive
conventional trains cost roughly two to
three cents per kilometer
high speed triple that
take a random route on a random day
let's say guangzhou to shanghai
the fastest route takes 6 hours 48
minutes and costs 124 dollars
the slow journey takes nearly a full day
but costs just 31
anyone watching this video would likely
jump at the opportunity to spend just 93
more dollars to save a whole 16 hours of
travel time
but the same can't be assumed in china
though there's no definitive value of
time most estimates use the average
hourly wage for business travelers and
no more than half that amount for
leisure
a quick back of the envelope calculation
reveals the 5.8 us dollars per hour
saved would be just marginally
worthwhile for the average business
traveler but not for the average leisure
traveler
another way of visualizing this is by
splitting the population into 10 equal
sized groups by income
what this shows is that 93 dollars is at
least half of weekly income for about 60
of china's population
of course in reality a disproportionate
number of the remaining highest income
travelers will simply opt for air travel
instead
others actually prefer the slower option
say for example you have one day of
meetings or events to attend the next
day
the sleeper train saves you from the one
night you'd otherwise spend at a hotel
anyway
now it would be wrong to say that demand
never materialized
just look at how busy stations get
around chinese new year
but the undertaking can hardly be called
a success
either
individual lines vary across the
spectrum from extremely popular to
catastrophically empty
although these numbers are wildly out of
date pay attention to the difference
between them
while some routes see 20 or 30 million
passengers a year like beijing to
shanghai or shanghai to nanjing
elsewhere quote the scale of investment
seems difficult to justify says a
beijing professor of economics
zhengzhou to xi'an is on average less
than 50 percent full
huay bay to shanghai as low as 21
in fact the majority of routes lose
money
according to the world bank out of 31
lines just five are at least break even
four were unable to pay back the
principal on their loans
11 also their interest and another 11
were unable even to cover their
operating costs
the 1700 kilometer route connecting
xinjiang to the capital of gansu
province in the largely empty gobi
desert runs just 8 out of the 320 daily
trains it was designed to handle
it loses money even on electricity
meaning there's no hope of paying back
its other operating costs to say nothing
of the interest on its loans and you can
forget about the principle
to keep the lights on operators have
continuously taken on new debt to pay
off the old in a vicious cycle
no one is quite sure how this ends
you might argue that high-speed rail
doesn't need to be profitable that it
can exist purely as a public good
this may be true but efficiency is
defined as output divided by input how
much do you get out for every dollar or
hour you put in
there's no denying china's incredible
output the fruits of which are plainly
clear to see
but too often our speed and scale
marveled at for their own sake with no
regard for their cost or context
the point is that china didn't crack the
code on high-speed rail it didn't
discover or invent some new method or
technology that made it cheaper faster
or more widespread
rather it paid the price a tremendous
price
and there's no reason to think that any
other country including the us couldn't
accomplish the same thing if it
similarly abandoned all financial
constraints
900 billion dollars of debt can buy
quite a lot of rail
even setting aside financial measures
it's unclear that high-speed rail had a
net positive effect
its singular almost religious obsession
with building more and more and more
high-speed rail well past its usefulness
has diverted funds away from
conventional rail on which freight
trains depend
while slow trains are certainly less
exciting they're under investment and in
some cases dismantling has led to a rise
in road transport which is good for no
one not least the planets
this is not the image of a government
free from political considerations
quietly and competently pursuing the
most optimal policies according to one
grand strategic plan
instead this like many of its
superlative laced mega projects the
three gorgeous dam the hong kong zhuhai
macau bridge and others are designed
first and foremost to impress
they benefit from a fundamental
psychological tendency to view other far
away countries as possessing the
solutions to our own
if america can't build cost-effective
high-speed rail because of endless red
tape its pervasiveness in china must be
evidence of success rather than a
reflection of its own unique flavor of
bureaucratic inefficiency
the mistake is assuming that because
china lacks your country's exact
problems then it must be free of its
own now all this inefficient development
could have been avoided if xi jinping
had just taken the right course on
today's sponsor skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of courses on
everything from pixel art to programming
i want to mention two courses that i
personally recommend the first is called
excel for the real world
this past year i've become borderline
addicted to spreadsheets i have one for
tracking my finances school and business
it's one of those general skills that
you absolutely will use at some point in
your life and hey it's also just weirdly
fun
the second is starting a successful side
hustle by ali abdul
it's the tutorial i wish i had seen when
starting this channel and can help you
make some extra money on the side
an annual subscription costs less than
10 bucks a month and the first 1 000
people to join by clicking the link on
screen now get a one month free trial
that's one full month you can take
unlimited courses with no restrictions
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
you